india reached a devastating coronavirus
milestone this morning
20 million cases since the pandemic
began
only the u.s has had more overall
in response a key government opponent is
demanding a nationwide lockdown
yogida lemai with our partners at the
bbc sent this report from
the home district of india's prime
minister
this is an area under lockdown at the
moment otherwise
these banks behind me would have been
full of pilgrims full
of tourists and what we're hearing from
many people here
is that the actual number of people
dying from covid19 is vastly more
than the official death toll the images
that we saw
in delhi's hospitals and crematoriums
shocked the world
but the situation here is even worse
even during normal times healthcare
facilities in areas like these
are fragile and in hospitals here we're
being told that
people don't have even the most basic of
care so oxygen shortages of course but
there are no doctors
no nurses to look at them in some
hospitals
we're told that they're not even getting
food
what we're seeing in this country is
that covert 19 is devastating its
biggest cities
but it's also spread to smaller towns
smaller areas
and villages in this country that was
yugita la mai with our partners at the
bbc
india reported more than 300 000 new
coveted cases today for the 13th day in
a row